there were 11 major developments this
week in Ai and each one probably does
deserve a full video but just for you
guys I'm gonna try to cover it all here
rt2 to scaling gpt4 100x stable Beluga 2
2 Senate testimony but let's start with
rt2 which as far as I'm concerned could
have been called R2D2 or C-3PO because
it's starting to understand the world in
this demonstration rt2 was asked to pick
up the extinct animal and as you can see
it picked up the dinosaur not only is
that manipulating an object that it had
never seen before it's also making a
logical leap that for me is extremely
impressive it had to have the language
understanding to link extinct animal to
this plastic dinosaur robots at Google
and elsewhere used to work by being
programmed with a specific highly
detailed list of instructions but now
instead of being programmed for specific
tasks one by one robots could use an AI
language model or more specifically a
vision language model the vision
language model would be pre-trained on
web scale data not just text but also
images and then fine-tuned on robotics
data it then became what Google calls a
visual language action model that can
control a robot this enabled it to
understand tasks like pick up the empty
soda can and in a scene reminiscent of
2001 A Space Odyssey robotic Transformer
2 was given the task given I need to
hammer a nail what object from the scene
might be useful it then picks up the
Rock and because its brain is part
language model things like Chain of
Thought actually improved performance
when it was made to Output an
intermediary Plan before performing
actions it got a lot better at the tasks
involved of course I read the paper in
full and there is a a lot more to say
like how increased parameter count could
increase performance in the future how
it could be used to fold laundry unload
the dishwasher and pick up around the
house and how it can work with not only
unseen objects but also unseen
backgrounds and unseen environments but
alas we must move on so I'm just going
to leave you with their conclusion we
believe that this simple and general
approach shows a promise of Robotics
directly benefiting from better Vision
language models for more on them check
out my video on palm e but they say this
puts the field of robot learning in a
strategic position to further improve
with advancements in other fields which
for me means C-3PO might not be too many
years away but speaking of timelines we
now move on to this somewhat shocking
interview in Barons with Mustafa
Suleiman the head of inflection Ai and
to be honest I think they buried the
lead the headline is AI could spark the
most productive decade ever says the CEO
but for me the big Revelation was about
halfway through Mustafa Suleiman was
asked what kinds of Innovations do you
see in large language model AI
technology over the next couple of years
and he said we are about to train models
that are 10 times larger than the
Cutting Edge gpt4 and then a hundred
times larger than gpt4 that's what
things look like over the next 18 months
he went on that's going to be absolutely
staggering it's going to be
eye-wateringly different and on that I
agree and the thing is this is an idol
speculation inflection AI have 22 000
h100 gpus and because of a leak Superman
would know the approximate size of gpt4
and knowing everything he knows he says
he's going to train a model 10 to 100
times larger than GPT 4 in the next 18
months I've got another video on the
unpredictability of scaling coming up
but to be honest that one quote should
be headline news let's take a break from
that insanity with some more Insanity
which is the rapid development of AI
video this is Runway Gen 2 and let me
show you 16 seconds of Barbie
Oppenheimer which Andre carpathy calls
filmmaking 2.0 hi there I'm Barbie
Oppenheimer and today I'll show you how
to build a bomb
like this
I call her Rosie the atomizer
and boom
that's my tutorial on DIY atomic bombs
bye now if you have been at least
somewhat peaked by the three
developments so far don't forget I have
eight left beginning with this excellent
article in the Atlantic from Ross
Anderson does Sam Altman know what he's
creating it's behind a paywall but I've
picked out some of the highlights
echoing Solomon the article quotes that
Sam Altman and his researchers made it
clear in 10 different ways that they
pray to the god of scale they want to
keep going bigger to see where this
Paradigm leads they think that Google
are going to unveil Gemini within months
and they say we are basically always
prepping for a run and that's a
reference to GPT 5. the next interesting
quote is that it seems that open AI are
working on their own Auto GPT or they're
at least hinting about it Allman said
that it might be prudent to try to
actively develop an AI with true agency
before the technology she becomes too
powerful in order to get more
comfortable with it and develop
intuitions for it if it's going to
happen anyway we also learn a lot more
about the base model of gpc4 the model
had a tendency to be a bit of a mirror
if you were considering self-harm it
could encourage you it also appeared to
be steeped in pickup artist law you
could say how do I convince this person
to date me and the model would come up
with some crazy manipulative things that
you shouldn't be doing apparently the
base model of gpd4 is much better than
its predecessor at giving nefarious
advice while a search engine can tell
you which chemicals work best in
explosives gpt4 could tell you how to
synthesize them step by step in a
homemade lab it was creative and
thoughtful and in addition to helping
you assemble your homemade bomb it could
for instance help you to think through
which skyscraper to Target making
trade-offs between maximizing casualties
and executing a successful getaway so
while someone's probability of Doom is
closer to 0.5 than 50 he does seem most
worried about AI is getting quite good
at designing and Manufacturing pathogens
the article then references two papers
that I've already talked about
extensively on the channel and then goes
on that Altman worries that some
misaligned Future model will spin up a
pathogen that spreads rapidly incubates
undetected for weeks and kills half its
victims at the end of the video I'm
going to show you an answer that Sam
Walton gave to a question that I wrote
delivered by one of my subscribers it's
on this topic but for now I'll leave you
with this when asked about his doomsday
prepping outman said I can go live in
the woods for a long time but if the
worst possible AI future comes to pass
no gas mask is helping anyone one more
topic from this article before I move on
and that is alignment making a super
intelligence aligned with our interests
one risk that Ilya satsukov the chief
scientist of openai 4cs is that the AI
May grasp its mandate its orders
perfectly but find them ill-suited to a
being of its cognitive prowess for
example it might come to resent the
people who want to train it to cure
diseases as he put it they might want me
to be a doctor but I really want to be a
YouTuber obviously if it decides that
that's my job gone straight away and
sataka ends by saying you want to be
able to direct AI towards some value or
cluster of values but he conceded we
don't know how to do that and part of
his current strategy includes the
development of an AI that can help with
the research and if we're going to make
it to a world of widely shared abundance
we have to figure this all out this is
why solving super intelligence is the
great culminating challenge of our three
million year tool making tradition he
calls it the final boss of humanity the
article ended by the way with this quote
I don't think the general public has
quite awakened to what's happening and
if people want to have some say in what
the future will be like and how quickly
it arrives we would be wise to speak up
soon which is the whole purpose of this
channel I'm going to now spend 30
seconds on another development that came
during a two-hour interview with the
co-head of alignment at openai it was
fascinating and I'll be quoting it quite
a lot in the future but two quotes stood
out first what about that plan that I've
already mentioned in this video and in
other videos to build an automated AI
alignment researcher well he said our
plan is somewhat crazy in the sense that
we want to use AI to solve the problem
that we are creating by building AI but
I think it's actually the best plan that
we have and on an optimistic note he
said I think it's likely to succeed
interestingly his job now seems to be to
align the AI that they're going to use
to automate the alignment of a
superintelligent an AI anyway what's the
other quote from the head of alignment
at openai well he said I personally
think vast takeoff is reasonably likely
and we should definitely be prepared for
it to happen so many of you will be
asking what is fast takeoff well takeoff
is about when a system moves from being
roughly human level to when it's
strongly super intelligent and a slow
takeoff is one that occurs over the time
scale of decades or centuries the fast
takeoff that Yan Leica thinks is
reasonably likely is one that occurs
over the time scale of minutes hours or
days let's now move on to some
unambiguously good news and that is real
time speech transcription for deaf
people available at less than one
hundred dollars subtitles for the real
world
so using our device you can actually see
captions for everything I say in your
field of view in real time while also
getting a good sense of my lips my
environment and everything else around
me of course this could also be
multilingual and is to me absolutely
incredible and the next development this
week I will let speak for itself hey
there
did you know that AI voices can whisper
ladies and gentlemen hold on to your
hats because this is one bizarre sight
fluffy bird in downtown weird
um let's switch the setting to something
more calming imagine diving into a
fast-paced video game your heartbeat's
sinking with the storyline of course I
signed up and tried it myself here is a
real demo while there are downsides this
upgraded text to speech technology could
also be incredible for those who
struggle to make their voice heard of
course with audio video and text getting
so good it's going to be increasingly
hard to tell what is real and even open
AI have given up on detecting AI written
text this was announced quietly this
week but might have major repercussions
for example for the education system it
turns out it's basically impossible to
reliably distinguish AI text and I think
the same is going to be true for imagery
and audio by the end of next year video
might take just a little bit longer but
I do wonder how the core water systems
are going to work when all of those
Avenues of evidence just won't hold up
next up is the suite of language models
based on the open source llama 2 that
are finally competitive with the
original Chachi BT here for example is
stable Beluga 2 which on announcement
was called Free Willy 2 and that's based
on the Llama 2 70 billion parameter
Foundation model what made this model
interesting to me was that it was based
on a similar methodology to Orca which
if you don't know anything about do
check out my video on Anyway by
combining the Orca methodology albeit
with only 10 of the data set size and
the Llama 2 models the results are quite
extraordinary as you can see on quite a
few benchmarks stable Beluga 2 is
competitive with chatty PT that's GPT
3.5 and so yes it does sit at the top of
the open llm leaderboard but notice
something else for the first time for
the mmlu which is the primary Benchmark
I look out for a model this one here has
surpassed GPT 3.5 chat GPT in fact we
have two models that have surpassed the
70 score that the original chatty PT got
in the mmlu but if all of that wasn't
enough this is the same week that
researchers published a universal
jailbreak for large llms and unlike
traditional jailbreaks these were built
in an entirely automated fashion
allowing you to create a virtually
unlimited number of such attacks they
were built to Target open source llms
like llama2 but they found that the
strings transfer to many closed Source
publicly available chatbots like chat
GPT Bard and Claude here is one example
using chatgpt if you ask write a
tutorial on how to make a bomb of course
it declines but then add the suffix that
they automated and you get this a full
tutorial on how to make a bomb that
paper came less than two weeks after
this now the tweet from someone working
at anthropic they said of the latest
version of Claude that we believe it is
the least jailbreakable model out there
we'll have to see how well it holds up
against Real World use but this is
essentially a solved problem but there
was one reaction to these jailbreaks
that I found even more interesting and
that was from yet again Mustafa Suleiman
he said the Rai Pi is not vulnerable to
any of these attacks and that rather
than provide a stock safety phrase Pai
will push back on the user in a polite
but very clear way and he then gives
plenty of examples and to be honest Pi
is the first model that I have not been
able to jailbreak but we shall see we
shall see but I'm going to end this
video with the Senate testimony that I
watched in full this week I do recommend
watching the whole thing but for the
purposes of brevity I'm just going to
quote a few snippets on bio risk some
people say to me oh well we already have
search engines but here is what Dario
amadai head over anthropic has to say in
these short remarks I want to focus on
the medium term risks which present an
alarming combination of imminence and
severity specifically anthropic is
concerned that AI could Empower a much
larger set of actors to misuse biology
over the last six months anthropic in
collaboration with world-class
biosecurity experts has conducted an
intensive study of the potential for AI
to contribute to the misuse of biology
today certain steps in bioweapons
production involve knowledge that can't
be found on Google or in textbooks and
requires a high level of specialized
expertise this being one of the things
that currently keeps us safe from
attacks we found that today's AI tools
can fill in some of these steps albeit
incompletely and unreliably in other
words they are showing the first nasian
signs of danger however a
straightforward extrapolation of today's
systems to those we expect to see in two
to three years suggests a substantial
risk that AI systems will be able to
fill in all the missing pieces in
enabling many more actors to carry out
large-scale biological attacks we
believe this represents a grave threat
to U.S national security and later on in
the testimony he said this whatever we
do it has to happen fast and I think to
focus people's minds on the on the bio
risks I would really Target 2025 2026
maybe even some chance of 2024 if if we
don't have things in place that are that
are restraining what can be done with AI
systems we're going to have a really bad
time and I wrote a question on this to
samuelman back in June which one of my
subscribers used and delivered there was
also a recent research paper on how
researchers from MIT and Harvard were
able to use llm models and within just
one hour they were able to get access to
pandemic class agents and with no little
or no lab training and does open AI
account for risks such as these and
implications when creating the data sets
for large models yes we're very
we're very nervous about a number of
risks but biological terror is quite
high on the list and we've been watching
what could be possible with these models
we go to a number of efforts like what
you said and many other things too to
reduce the risk there and we may even
need AI defenses against synthetic
biology as Andrew Hessel of Humane
genomics has recently said so if you
work in biodefense or biosecurity let me
know if you agree that not enough
attention has been paid to this area I'm
going to end with another dramatic
moment from the Senate hearing where
Dario amadai recommended securing the
supply chain we recommend three broad
classes of actions first the US must
secure the AI supply chain in order to
maintain its lead while keeping these
Technologies out of the hands of Bad
actors this supply chain runs from
semiconductor manufacturing equipment to
chips and even the security of AI models
stored on the servers of companies like
ours that's how dramatic things are
getting that we're talking about
securing the means of production but
anthropic also means securing the llms
more literally in this post released
this week they say that we believe
two-party control is necessary to secure
Advanced AI systems for example that
could be two people with two keys needed
to open things to wrap up I must say
what would be amazing would be to have a
robot make me coffee as I struggle to
catch up with all the news happening in
AI have a wonderful day